[Musique]
accepter ou refuser les cookies on nous
pose la question à chaque fois qu'on
visite d'un site internet les cookies ou
témoins servent à conserver vos
préférences langue d'usagé article le
laisser dans votre panier ecce terra
mais ils servent aussi à savoir ce que
vous faites sur internet pour que des
annonceurs puce vous ciblez ce qui a
énervé royalement des européens et c'est
la loi européenne qui oblige maintenant
les entreprises à vous permettre de
paramétrer les cookies comme internet et
universel des sites de partout dans le
monde se conforment cette loi d'ailleurs
le québec va bientôt faire pareil le
fédéral à l'intention de le faire aussi
et l'intention est bonne sauf que un
avertissement à chaque nouvelle page
c'est énervant d'ailleurs bien des
européens finissent par cliquer oui oui
oui sans distinction parce qu'ils sont
fatigués paramétrer
soyons francs nous aussi parce que
parent maîtrise n'est pas simple selon
alexandre plourde d'option consommateurs
on devrait nous permettre de refuser en
bloc d'être pisté par des cookies ou
autrement mais nos législateurs ont
préféré faire comme les européens alors
ces avertissements vont être énervant
pour longtemps mais si vous êtes patient
servez vous en passez le mot